Mr Speaker being pro-education is being
pro-growth
but providing our children with a good
education is not just an economic
Mission it's a moral mission one to
which my right honorable friend the
Prime Minister has always been deeply
committed
education secretaries particularly
from Surrey Heath and from bognor Regis
we have risen nine places in the global
League tables for maths and reading in
the last seven years
thank you
I still however have concerns that not
all School leavers get the skills they
need for a modern economy
but for the first time ever this country
has a conservative education secretary
who left school at 16 to become an
apprentice and knows firsthand why good
skills matter
there are many important initiatives in
place but as Chancellor I want to know
the answer to one simple question will
every young person leave the education
system with the skills they would get in
Japan Germany or Switzerland so I have
appointed
so I've appointed Sir Michael Barber to
advise me and my right honorable
friendly education secretary on the
implementation of our skills reform
program
as we raise the skill levels of our
school leavers I want also to ensure
that even in an economic crisis the
Improvement in school standards
continues to accelerate
some have suggested putting VAT on
independent school fees as a way of
increasing core funding for schools
which would raise about 1.7 billion
pounds
but according to certain estimates that
would result in up to 90 000 children
from the Independent sector switching to
State schools giving with one hand only
to take away with another
so
so so
instead of being ideological I'm going
to be practical
standards to continue to rise for every
single child we're going to do more than
protect the school's budget we're going
to increase it and I can announce today
[Music]
next year and the year after we will
invest an extra 2.3 billion pounds per
annum in our schools our message to
heads and teachers and classroom
assistants is thank you for your
brilliant work we need it to continue
and in difficult economic circumstances
a conservative government is investing
more in the public service that defines
all our futures
[Applause]